saremi le meeting de soutien à alain
juppé s'est déroulée dans une atmosphère
particulière car l'intervenant principal
n'était autre que deux minutes perben
l'ancien maire de chalon sur saône ne
s'était plus exprimé localement depuis
2002 et on le croyait même retraité de
la vie politique
j'avais dit que je ferais plus de
politique et puis bon je dis justement
on fait un peu c'est pour deux raisons
la première j'y reviendrai c'est parce
que la situation du pays est difficile
et qu'il faut mener une politique
ambitieuse et courageuse pendant les
cinq prochaines années et puis ensuite
bien sûr continuer mais l'autre raison
c'est parce que alain juppé c'est
quelqu'un de l'air en moins d'une heure
dominique perben a déroulé les idées le
programme de son ami alain apaisé
rassemblé réformer en sont les mots clés
c'est vrai que dans mon amitié pour
alain juppé
il y à la reconnaissance chez lui de ce
qui est très important pour moi c'était
dans le sens de l'intérêt général
une certaine conception de l'état une
certaine conception de la république et
je pense que beaucoup de mes amis ici
partagent cette manière de mai qu'on
pense réellement les militants de ce
meeting sont ils venus par amitié pour
dominique ou en soutien à l' un peu
dominique perben
aussi elle ajouté on est très heureux de
voir que maintenait s'engage son tour
national
et c'est comme ça qu'on est très heureux
de vous recevoir
et c'est sur une marseillaise entre
nostalgie et à venir que le meeting des
supporters d'alain juppé s'est clôturée